hey dr. Wallach is Anthony Mansoura
distributor nurse and health coach and
just wanted today again god bless you
and thank you for your good work and
your time here okay thank you sir very
kind how can we help you today yeah I
have a gentleman so I have a friend
whose son is in his twenties he's a
bright man's a Social Work background
he's endeavoring to finish college for
another degree but he's hindered due to
his current situation this gentleman has
been having episodes of psychosis he's
still currently on there he's still
currently psychotic based on the most
recent report he's actually hospitalized
he won't be released till later this
summer but he's been hospitalized over
220 days over the last four years he's
been diagnosed with schizophrenia which
is catatonic in nature he's been
experiencing episodes of catatonia over
time from a report from his mother
doesn't really have any other health
issues including digestive issues skin
issues they said he does have dealt with
occasional sleeplessness in the past but
that's not really amazing any weight you
know do you know how much he weighs yeah
he's a hundred he's in his 180 S range
180 pounds somewhere around there and
he's about okay here we go
here we go first thing he's got
nutritional deficiency and it could be
secondary to gluten intolerance okay and
I've talked about this many times when
people have psychoses psycho they have
schizophrenia they had depression man
compression bipolar disease PTSD AED
ADHD those kinds of things these things
are all cosmetics triple efficiencies
which are many of them not all but many
of them are detectable with a hair no
need to get a hair analysis on him you
need to get a hold of that book raros
ventures and get a hold of that book
ravers nature's chapter 11 tells you how
to collect the hair how to package you
where to send this how to interpret the
results and after the hair is collected
you know the information what would you
give this guy Shar 180 pounds you've got
all these emotional problems here use
hospital
I need so bad ok charmagne we only have
seconds here because we've got a couple
other colors we're gonna try and get to
so what would you do for Anthony's
friend the son
oK we've got all these emotional
problems that in supplement again my
gluten free diet no wheat barley rye
oats and no fried foods and over no fat
and there's also getting my two healthy
brain and heart packs synaptic and I'd
get him on some like free radical or
yeah what about for brain metabolism and
that kind of stuff ok how about D stress
de-stress yes
James and I should in what and and of
course he needs to adhere to the diet
strictly because that's going to it
needs it needs uh what do you mean
niacin okay now those 22 days his body
weight and then call this every couple
examining will walk you guys through
this but this can resolve itself very
quickly but get that here analysis